forty-eight hours has disturbing new
information about the relationship
between a murdered California police
officer and his ex-wife officer Daniel
Green was shot to death inside his home
in 2015 at first
Erica Sandoval denied being involved in
the murder but then she changed her
story in his first Network TV interview
Greene's twin brother tells 48 hours
Erin Moriarty butts and of all seemed
capable of violence On February 6 2015
in mid afternoon time Stood Still in
Tulare County that was the day says
district attorney Tim Ward that police
officer Daniel green was ambushed by a
killer who shot him four times in quick
succession this was not anything other
than a cold-blooded calculated execution
Daniel was 31 years old an 11 year
veteran of the Exeter Police Department
in central California almost immediately
sheriff's deputies were aware of a
possible suspect Green's ex-wife Erica
Sandoval who had in the past seemed
capable of violence
Matt Green is Daniel Greene's identical
twin brother she had cut up the couch
and she had cut up the bed springs and
stabbed holes in the wall taking a
bottle of pancake syrup and just spread
it all over the carpet just a ridiculous
amount of vandalism Daniel and Erika
have what everyone called a toxic
relationship da Ward says Erica who was
eventually arrested and charged with her
ex-husband's murder killed Daniel one
week after he posted this Instagram
photo featuring his new 20 year-old
girlfriend Brenda Vela is it possible
that Daniel Green would still be alive
if he had never posted that picture on
social media that's an impossible
question but you wonder it's such a
tragedy that we'll never know but it
does point to motive and in the three
days leading up to the murder
Erica bombarded Daniel with 167 phone
calls
at trial Erica admit she killed her
ex-husband but she says it was to
protect their young son Aaron Moriarty
is with us Erin good morning for days
she was on the stand why did she take
the stand in her own defense well she
had no choice really because number one
we know that she pulled the trigger and
I should point out she couldn't really
say self-defense because she shot him at
and this is hard for me to talk about
but she shot him at a time that he was
most vulnerable he was actually on the
toilet so she had to take the stand to
explain to the jurors what was going on
in her mind but why we picked this story
is you know everybody called it a toxic
relationship because we don't think of
men being victims of domestic violence
why not a male police officer yeah we
don't and even his friends like his
friends I spoke with them and they
regret that they didn't take it more
seriously they kind of blamed the two of
them and certainly both of them there
was an interesting similarity between
the looks of the two women yes it is but
that is interesting to where social
media then played a part in this just
like domestic violence if you try to
leave posting a picture kind of set
things off at least that's what the
prosecution believes we'll be right back
Thank You Erin
Thank You Erin